en chine l'inquiétude est également en
très vive et notamment un canton la
ville la plus touchée déjà par le strass
envoyés spéciaux philippe rochot sylvain
viaut ses poulets qui alimente les
restaurants de canton sont devenus
suspects le gouvernement chinois a
interdit aujourd'hui l'importation de
poulet du vietnam mais n'en continuent
pas moins d'écouler les siens
or c'est d'ici deux cantons est partie
l'épidémie de grippe aviaire il y a 6
ans et qui se réveille un peu partout en
asie corée japon vietnam ont abattu plus
de 3 millions de poulets et de canards
mais la chine se contente pour l'heure
de simples mesures de désinfection de
ses marchés aux animaux pour l'instant
l'impact n'est pas grand je pense qu'il
n'ya pas cette maladie ici ce même
marché a déjà dû sacrifier 3000 civette
soupçonnées de véhiculer le strass et
redoutent de devoir supprimer sa
volaille car les chercheurs s'inquiètent
de la facilité de transmission du virus
de la grippe aviaire
on n'est pas encore sûr de la de
contagiosité d'homme à homme pour la
grippe du poulet mais par contre le
virus de la grippe du poulet peut se
transmettre par les voies aériennes donc
pas simplement à au contact étroit entre
deux personnes
alors dans les aéroports ou les gares de
chinon traque de nouveau les voyageurs
qui ont de la fièvre
premier signe d' alerte de la grippe
aviaire ou de la pneumopathie
le virus de la grippe du poulet est sans
doute plus inquiétant que celui du
strass mais il n'effraie pas pour
l'heure les habitants de canton car il
n'y a pas de preuve qu'il se transmet
d'homme à homme